is not the same country that it was two
and a half years ago when I came into
office Iran was the number one state of
terror throughout the world there were
18 sites of confliction in my first week
when I spoke with the folks at the
Pentagon including lots of generals and
lots of other military experts 18 sites
of confliction meaning 18 sites of big
problems every one of them was backed by
Iran or in some cases actually using
Iranian soldiers but at a minimum
Iranian wealth much of it given and the
ridiculous deal where they were given a
hundred and fifty billion dollars plus
1.8 billion dollars in cash and they use
that money for some bad purposes with
that being said I think that Iran is a
country of tremendous potential we're
not looking for leadership change we're
not looking for that kind of change this
country has been through that many times
before that doesn't work we're looking
for no nuclear weapons no ballistic
missiles and a longer period of time
very simple we can have it done in a
very short period of time and I really
believe that Iran can be a great nation
I'd like to see that happen but they
can't have nuclear weapons okay thank
you excuse me if the circumstances were
correct toward the right I would
certainly agree to that but in the
meantime they have to be good players
you understand what that means and they
can't do what they were saying they're
going to do because if they do that
they're going to be met with really very
violent force we have no choice so I
think they're going to be good I really
think they'd like to and by the way
president McCrone told me every step
that he was making yesterday a lot of
you said oh he came in and he told me
long before he came in what was
happening what was I didn't think was
appropriate to meet yesterday too soon
and things have to be worked out first
but President McCrone told me exactly
what was happening who was coming what
time they were coming where they
going to meet and after the meeting he
told me exactly what happened and I
think he had a very positive meeting
Prime Minister Abbey of Japan also a
large purchaser of oil from Iran he was
also very much involved and you know
look he knows everybody there so he was
a very very positive force but I have to
tell you the president's done an
excellent job and we're gonna see how it
all turns out maybe it works maybe it
doesn't I said all the time about
everything maybe it works and maybe it
doesn't but I'll tell you what we made a
ridiculous deal we gave 150 billion even
1.8 billion and we got nothing
we got nothing and by the way that
agreement was so short term that it
expires in a very short period of time
with a country you don't make a deal
that sure countries last for a long
times and you know do short term deal
especially when you're paying that kind
of money so I had the good feelings
about Iran I have good feelings that
it'll work I know many Iranians living
in New York City have many friends from
Iran they're incredible people
incredible people so the last thing I'd
like to see is a big problem but we have
to do what we have to do okay yes yes
president McCrone did you did you seek
president Trump's permission before you
invited foreign minister Zarif or did
you simply inform him that he was coming
thanks for his very precise questions
but to be very clear and and we we are
part of GCP way we decided to remain as
this dual so we are very much interested
by the situation as a sovereign country
that's why we want the different parties
to move on the other side as president
Trump made it very clear over the summer
we never spoke on behalf of other
countries we just tried tested some
solutions and to see if we can find an
agreement with different countries
so we took an initiative this summer to
make a proposal a technical one I got
the reaction from Iran's who president
sorry visits on Friday and Friday
morning in purse after the discussion we
had at the g7 dinner on Saturday evening
I thought that it was very clear about
where we can go together
so the day after I decided to invite as
friends Minister Zarif so I informed
before making it I informed President
Trump that it was my idea not to involve
the United States not to say this is on
behalf of you of everybody but you same
as France I think it would be a good
idea to ask him to go back and try to
negotiate something separately so I did
it on my own I informed before making it
President front
it was informed at each minute about the
solution the situation sorry and the
idea for me was in case of sexual move
and important move and appropriate
solutions perhaps to have meetings
between ministers not that president
trans level because president front
level is president rouhani
so this is my precise answer this is a
French initiative but made by a clear
information of the US president before
information as well of the three
Europeans and each timeline from
President Trump in order to monitor the
situation and to approach it together is
something more was adapted I have to say
the jcpoa was a deal should not have
been entered into a lot of things could
have happened that would have been much
different they're allowed to test
ballistic missiles you're not allowed to
go to various sites to check and some of
those sites are the most obvious sites
for the creation or the making of
nuclear
weapons and those things have to be
changed and other things have to be
changed and I will tell you I have very
good feelings about it
I think that we're going to do something
it may not be immediately but I think
ultimately we're going to do something
as I said Iran is a much different
country than it was two and a half years
ago and we can get that back and I'd
encourage it I actually had friends
years ago many years ago they were in
the real estate business and they were
in Iran and they were building houses
and building housing and building office
buildings and apartment houses and they
did very well they made a lot of money
and to this day they're not exactly the
youngest developers anymore but I tell
you they were young when they went over
there they made a lot of money and they
loved the people and they loved what was
going on and it's a country with
tremendous potential I also say that by
the way with respect to North Korea Kim
jong-un who had gotten to know extremely
well first lady has gotten to know Kim
jong-un and I think she did agree with
me he is a man with a country that has
tremendous potential you're in between
China Russia and South Korea people want
to get the South Korea they got to get
there somehow and if they're going to do
anything other than essentially fly they
want to go through so railroads and
everything else so many things want to
happen there I think that North Korea
has tremendous economic potential and I
think that Kim jong-un sees that he
would be the leader and I think he sees
the tremendous potential that it's got
with respect to around the same thing
Iran is incredible people an incredible
country potentially location that's a
little rough neighborhood but eventually
it's going to be a beautiful
neighborhood I think that it's going to
be I think it's going to work out and I
really believe that those countries that
went into the original deal that more
and more are agreeing with what I did
but I think those countries are going to
be saying thank you someday I
they're going to be saying including
France including the president because I
think we did the right thing I know we
did the right thing if for no other
reason it's just too short
it's almost expiring if you think about
it and somebody said well you'll go and
make an extension no no they're great
negotiators look at what they did to get
the deal look at what they did to John
Kerry and to President Obama look what
happened where they're bringing plane
loads of cash plane looks big planes
757s Boeing 757s coming in and loaded up
with cash what kind of a deal is that
so I think a lot of good things are
going to happen and I just want to say
this because I've spoken a lot with the
president this last two and a half days
we've never had a better relationship we
had a lunch that lasted for quite a
while that many of you got to see who
was the two of us no staff no anything
he wasn't trying to impress his people I
wasn't trying to impress his people we
were just trying to impress each other
and I'll tell you what it was the best
period of time we've ever had and we
accomplished a lot I don't mean just gee
whiz wasn't that nice he's a very
capable man he's doing a great job for
France he did an incredible job for the
g7 and I just want to thank you and you
go ahead to your news conference and
very special this was a very special
very unified two-and-a-half days I know
one thank you for thank you thank you
[Applause]